we've done many videos on the price
elasticity of demand now we're going to
focus on the price elasticity of supply
and it's a very similar idea it's just
being applied to supply now it's a
measure of how sensitive our quantity
supplied is to percent changes in price
and we will calculate it as our percent
change
in
quantity supplied
for a given
percent change in price
percent
change
in
price
now to make this a little bit more
tangible let's look at a simple market
let's say this is the market for apples
right over here
where our vertical axis is price and
this could be thousands of dollars per
ton and then our horizontal axis is
quantities and maybe this isn't tons per
day and this supply schedule and this
supply curve are essentially describing
the same data
so let's think about our price
elasticity of supply as we go from point
a
point a to point b well on the supply
schedule
point a is this point right over here
our price is four our quantity is one
and point b is right over here so let us
calculate from point a to point b
our price
elasticity of supply so first of all
what is going to be our percent change
in price well we're going from four to
six so it's an increase of two so our
percent change in price is going to be
equal to
two is how much we increase from a base
of four
times one hundred percent
and that of course is going to be equal
to a 50
increase in price and then what is going
to be our percent change in quantity
well we're going from one to two so
we're starting at a base of one we are
increasing by one and then multiply that
times one hundred percent that gives us
one hundred percent
so when we have a fifty percent increase
in price that resulted going from point
a to point b in a hundred percent
inquiry increase in quantity supplied so
100 percent divided by 50 percent that
is going to give us this is going to be
equal to 2. now what if we go from point
b to point c so this is point c right
over here i encourage you pause this
video and see if you can calculate the
price elasticity of supply when going
from point b to point c
well we're going to do a similar similar
calculation
our change our percent change in price
we start at a base of 6 and we are
increasing by two
so we're going to multiply that times
100 percent so that is approximately
this is one-third times 100 it's
approximately
33.3 percent and then what is our
percent change in quantity supplied well
we are going to go from two
to three
so we start at a base of two we increase
by one
so plus one and multiply times one
hundred percent and so that's going to
be given it's going to be equal to 50
percent
and so
when we have a
one-third increase or 33.3 percent
increase in our price we have a 50
increase of our quantity supplied when
we go from point b
to
point c right over here and then one way
to think about it is 50 percent divided
by a third is the same thing as 50 times
3 and so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to
1.5
so just as we saw when we calculated
price elasticity of demand even when you
have a linear curve here your price
elasticity of supply can change it is
not the same thing as slope now another
thing to keep in mind is the way that i
calculated price elasticity of supply in
this video which is arguably the
simplest way you would not get the same
value when you're calculating the
magnitude going from a to b than if you
went from b to a there are slightly more
advanced techniques the midpoint
technique for example that will give you
the same answer regardless of which
direction you go in but that's beyond
the scope of this first video
now just as we discussed in the demand
case there are cases that you would
consider to be more inelastic supply and
cases where you would consider to be
more elastic supply
so one way to think about it is if the
magnitude of your price elasticity of
supply is less than one and of course
this is magnitude so it's going to be
greater than or equal to zero well then
you're talking about inelastic price
elasticity of supply
in elastic that's a situation in which
our quantity supplied is not going to
change so much depending on
is not going to be so sensitive to our
change in price
now if our
price elasticity of supply is greater
than one that's generally considered to
be elastic for a given percent change in
price you're getting a larger than that
percent change in quantity supplied